well I chose kind of email and trying to
decide between photography and
communication design and since it's for
the top communications design schools
I chose cerebellum I was initially
looking for combine programs for arts
and technology science and design
interdisciplinary and it was my first
choice right along the graduates from
here get really good jobs they're very
well placed in the field honeymoon
degree is instantly respected people
love hiring Carnegie Mellon students
they have like full-blown confidence in
our ability in our determination my dad
is a finance professor himself so he
looked at all the curriculums and they
felt that Carnegie Mellon was very
strong just the faculty support just the
friends that you make from all over the
world and I think that's that's what
makes it worth coming right we came to
visit here actually one day during one
of the April views days and we talked to
mark Selleck his attitudes about women
in computer science and encouraging
women in the technical fields and
strategies that they've employed at
Carnegie Mellon to maintain women in
computer science it really interested me
what he had to say this campus itself
felt intimate and it felt warm and
welcoming after a while you can kind of
just walk on a campus and tell if some
place you'd want to be and Carnegie
Mellon when I walked on the campus I
could tell it right away I really
enjoyed the people I came on a overnight
weekend sleeping bag weekend and I had a
great time here the campus was great the
faculty was great students were great I
felt like this would be a place I was
fit in so all around there's nothing
more that I could think of that I would
want from a college than the things that
Carnegie Mellon has to offer
academically carnegie-mellon is a
wonderful school especially for
engineering being one of the top schools
in computer science it really made sense
to go here once I was accepted when I
say I'm going to Carnegie Mellon they're
like oh that's amazing the computer
school like yeah it is you know it's
it's awesome but you know they also have
a really really good drama school
Kearney Mellon students love what they
do
we're also ambitious everybody is so
driven and so motivated and so
intelligent professors in these
disciplines who who are leading their
fields and students who are utterly
geniuses everybody comes together and we
can all learn from each other the
professors are always there their doors
are always open for you to go and you
can get personal level they know so much
there's such an extensive background and
I swear to god she knows everything like
about everything my advisor for
engineering and public policy just the
type of person that I'll answer my email
at 4:30 in the morning and I'm like what
are you doing up I literally have gone
into her office at least one semester
and that fix my life the teachers here
really really care about your growth I
think that's the Carnegie Mellon example
carne melon is definitely a really
diverse campus it's just a great melting
pot to learn about many different things
you didn't know I think this campus is
incredibly diverse I've met people from
so many countries I really lost count my
suitemates are from Japan this one from
Thailand just geographically you know
all over and like my roommate he's from
Germany of all the schools in the whole
world you can come to you picked
Carnegie Mellon in Pittsburgh and you
live in a Germany like that's like
fascinating people are so diverse here
like people who are into the arts and at
the same time there's people there doing
like from the line technology even
though you're in that major and you're
focused on that they always have
interests outside of that like one of my
friends is a CS major but he's also in
sound bytes which is the acapella group
you name it I have a friend who does it
it's really great it's like everybody
just forms together and you form like
the superhero power bond where you put
all your friends together and you cover
all the forces and it's so awesome so
the more diverse the better and I think
our NEMA is quite diverse which is great
my favorite Carnegie Mellon tradition is
definitely carnival will have buggy
races and then booths buggy sweepstakes
are awesome it's amazing to see students
building vehicles in you know forty
miles an hour around hairpin turns most
of the time successfully so my favorite
tradition here at Carnegie Mellon is the
bagpipe band and it's just a great thing
to have because it's part of that
Scottish tradition you know being the
Tartans and all my favorite Carnegie
Mellon tradition is the fence you can
paint the fence at 12 a.m. you have to
stay round the clock and guard the fence
so that nobody else takes in so it's a
really great thing well it's a beautiful
day outside I love hanging out on the
cut it's a nice place to relax lie down
on the grass lay out in the Sun and
you're on the side of like Schenley Park
which is this giant like green space but
you can hike through bike through
whatever I really recommend living in
freshman dorm is freshman year you get
to meet a lot of people they're like
family with your friends on the hall and
you hang out with them and go to class
with them the doors are always open so
somebody's always coming or stirring
things up there's just there's so much
going on you can always find something
to be doing here and it's just what you
want to take advantage of then I've been
involved with the Asian student
organization and salsa Spanish and Latin
Student Association all kinds of
different groups and I'm involved in an
organization like sighs women engineers
which has been really good for like
contacts and support to get more
involved socially as I've joined Tri
Delta it's one of the national
sororities on campus I love to play
basketball when someone track to me and
then we have things like the Cricket
Club and the ballroom dancing club
whether it's in the box out of the box
not even in the field or on the plant I
mean this is the place to come to
so there definitely is a lot of stuff to
do in the Pittsburgh area I'm usually at
Southside Friday night Saturday night
which is great because there's good
places to eat take it go to the baseball
games football games there's a lot of
art and music in the area which makes it
really cool there's so many things to do
just right around the corner on campus
there are definitely some nice little
neighborhoods around there's some cool
areas our Squirrel Hill and shady side
there's always great movies playing down
the waterfront or on the south side
another thing I like is skiing over at
Seven Springs it's only like an hour
away I really liked that I had
everything that a a larger metropolitan
area would have it's so hard to tell
people you know come to Carnegie Mellon
these with this it's like I'm the
Carnegie Mellon because of all of this
my philosophy is college is about
classes but college is also about life
there are tons of opportunities to do
just extra so just go beyond the
classroom beyond your homeworks beyond
your projects go out dive in everything
headfirst if there's an opportunity that
you're questionable about why not give
it a shot
I promise you you will be a part of
things that you won't have a chance of
being a part of anywhere else coming
here focused and willing to have fun and
open because it's an awesome experience